i feel very bad for everyone who's ever
dated me with the possible exclusion of
my wife to whom i am married
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming
queen um a girl who's
been mad about the president before
and remains so to this day elise morales
and with us today guys we have such a
fun guest he
is a writer and producer on jesus and
mero he's a stand-up he's an author but
before all of that
he was a graduate of stoneham high
school it's josh gonzalez
that's true that is i always insist it
not just for this show
that that is a credit that gets brought
up is that i am a stoneham high school
graduate
i walked the stage at graduation i
walked the stage walked the halls walked
all over that place
what was your mascot we were the
stoneham
spartans and i think they still are so
it was like a
mascot yeah just an old-timey uh
greek guy in a helmet with a sword
you know like like how soccer is
honestly as far as mascots go we can
keep the spartan
there are some weird mascots out there
that need to be changed
yeah to a weird christian elementary
school we were the crusaders that's
actually
do they keep that i think they still are
i don't check in on them
that often my high school was the
cougars which isn't bad but then there's
there's a sexual
connotation i think that one's still
safe like you show the picture and
people get it
they're not like oh are you you're the
um the fearful high
milfs or whatever
well um i can't remember who it was uh
suggested
that the school should have a dance
where like older girls
ask
[Laughter]
which would be [ __ ] tight very funny
yeah i think as long as it's like
seniors to freshmen and not they don't
like
import a bunch of like 52 year old moms
yeah yeah as long as it's not like
actual adult women it's kind of fun
actually
yeah we're having a good time
okay so one like flavor of high school
is stoneham high school would you say
okay so i'll let me describe it in a way
that i think makes sense
and then you tell me if i just wildly
miss the mark of your question
it is it's a public school about 800
kids
suburban um it was
big enough that it there was like stuff
like they're all the different clubs and
stuff
but i always describe it to people as
like it was small enough that like
people had to kind of double dip in
various social strata
so like when i was a freshman
the the the guy who was like the lead in
the musical that year
or one of the leads in the musical uh
the spring musical was also like on the
varsity soccer team
um
marcos you're doing great yeah i think
he is doing great he's like a
playing music professionally yeah he
rules that's
that's so interesting because my high
school was bigger than that
but i would still say like suburban high
school and i felt
there was not a lot of overlap between
the theater and
sports community oh yeah this was very
overlapping like it was like everybody
it was like okay there's 800 kids
but there's like 2 400 types of person
we need
so like okay you're a burnout who's on
the math team
and like you're a uh like you're a goth
and you um and you like
play ice hockey or whatever like it's
just like everybody had like
the goth ice hockey player is so great
to think about
yeah i mean like that is um that one is
like the most hypothetical of all but i
think it might have existed
i like don't remember that much about
the hockey team honestly but like there
were
there were so many people where it was
like okay you're the president of the
french club
and you're on the the varsity basketball
team
and you're on yearbook or whatever and
it just it felt like
um on one level there were like kids
that weren't as
involved but i feel like everybody kind
of because there were so many
so few people comparatively everyone got
to like
be a little multifaceted just like how
they were
how we all presented ourselves to each
other um
which is kind of cool yeah no that so
you answered my question perfectly you
had no reason
thank you um
so what would you say that you're like
what was your venn diagram
of teen activities social groups
etc i was all over the place
um i was i was
very screech-like
which will come into play when you see
the picture of me yes i was gonna say i
think that we now have to pull
okay so let's pull up the picture
because it said screech like
yes so this is
this is my driver's license picture from
when i my first driver's license
and i'm uh kind of
as much as i'm famously anything i am
famously bald
at this point in history and so it's
just like i don't
look anything like that at this point
but i had like a big
kind of that i think the the colloquial
term is jufro
um yes
and i was very um
i could like i was like kind of a big
soft dork who moved in a lot of social
circles so like
i hung out with the kid like i played uh
junior varsity basketball when i was a
sophomore
and i did yearbook and math team and i
was in all the
theater productions like from starting
like
dabbling freshman year and then being
more and more involved
until uh senior year like when i was in
junior and senior year when i was in all
the plays and like
i hosted the variety show and uh
there i was i was class president for a
while and like oh my god
yeah so i just like kind of dabbled
but i was like i wasn't cool
i mean you can see from the picture
that's not like a cool guy
picture like unless you're talking
unless i'm i'm like not that old that i
went to high school in welcome back
cotter times
but i was just like i got along with
everybody
uh and just like did a lot of stuff i
was like a
like kind of a um like tracy flick
from election but like without the edge
like i was just like
well i have to do everything like part
of it was
i like doing a lot of stuff and part of
it was like oh this will look good on
college applications
and like you know what i mean like so i
was just always
doing stuff yeah so that's
so were you like super college motivated
at that time because i was like crazy
when it came to applying for college
applications i like convinced myself
that you had to apply to hundreds of
schools and so i made
a giant list it was like it should have
it should have been a sign to my parents
that an intervention was needed
i was i was like
motivated but also reluctant like
just i like doing also and like doing
things that were hard
um which that's like a great description
of my
personal work ethic it's like i go super
hard
with stuff where i'm like oh this is fun
like i love doing stand up i'll go out
every night or like
uh you know i love this kind of writing
work and then if someone's like oh but
you should like do a treatment for a
show that you could maybe
sell i'd be like but that sounds like
boring and nobody wants to see it and
like i like doing the stuff where people
are like
good job yeah yeah yeah nice guy
everybody came to the assembly and it
was really good
we thought it was going to be boring but
it was actually pretty fun so
um but i was like i think
i was like very grades conscious
and very like extracurricular conscious
but i also like i think i graduated
kind of at the at the point just before
everybody was applying to like a zillion
schools so i applied to
i think i did six applications and a
couple of them were like
common app stuff so that i could knock
them out at once but um
i also didn't have like the dream
school like i wasn't like if i don't go
to
swarthmore i will perish like i just
we did like a bunch of rote family road
trips i think i was really only
considering stuff like kind of
up and down from like new england
through the mid-atlantic so it wasn't
like i wasn't like flying out to
to the west coast to look at schools
because i like i think i've always liked
being valued being close to my family
even though i'm not
i don't go home even now i don't go home
that much i just like the fact that like
i can yeah like if i need to get in a
car
and go see you that's why i went to
university of delaware because it's like
three hours from northern virginia the
perfect
amount of time anybody can get to
anybody if they want but like
you also call me before you're going to
visit
yes i i wouldn't i my parents have
pretty decent boundaries about that
stuff
so like they were never just like
popping by which is good because i went
to i went to brandeis which is like
25 35 minutes depending on traffic away
from where i grew up
so back to doing all the like
plays and the assemblies and stuff i
like was there any greater high than
just crushing at the assembly like i
feel like
that stuff that feeling of like the
entire school
is here and um
i was able to like do a funny bit at the
assembly and make everybody laugh was
like
i didn't realize i was like doing comedy
at that time but
that's how it made me feel i did
we had this big variety show called so
this was like uh this is like a real
double dipping like i was talking about
before
facet of my high school which is there's
this big variety show that happens
every i think it's the spring and
the each class so people students
apply to do like variety acts like
singing or playing you playing music or
a dance like a choreographed dance
number
but also each class
does a skit like a comedy sketch um
uh which it's like so each class like
writes and performs a comedy sketch
amongst them and the the people
in charge of writing the sketch
are the class officers so like president
vice president treasurer secretary
that's like who did it and so like i was
class vice president
freshman year and we did like a pretty
straightforward i forget what the
i forget what the theme was that year
but our
sketch was how the grinch stole carnival
ball which is
the variety show and so and i i
basically
i did the bulk of the writing i think
everybody was kind of like talking about
what it should be and there was a big
meeting with
every because everyone also everyone who
wants to be in it has to
be allowed to be in it so like everyone
from the class
so it's like there's a production of the
vagina monologues like that at
university of delaware wherever
he tries out yep for sure
and it's like a logistical problem
hello everyone today's episode of the
roast
of your teenage self podcast is brought
to you
by magic spoon can i tell you
that magic spoon's actually causing an
issue at my house because
i got free magic spoon and the free
magic spoon is for me
and yeah i have a fiancee who just
thinks that he can be eating the free
magic spoon
um and the thing about magic spoon is
that it's so good
that you can't really have you need to
buy enough for two people if you're
gonna have two people be eating it
because otherwise it goes away too fast
so listen up growing up cereal was one
of the best parts of being a kid but i
had to give it up because then i
realized
it's full of sugar it's full of junk
food i can't really eat like that it
gives me acne etc etc but then
magic spoon entered my life
magic spoon is zero sugar 11 grams of
protein and only three
net grams of carbs in each serving they
come in four delicious flavors which are
again
tearing my home life apart those flavors
are
cocoa fruity floss flosted
frosted and blueberry and i'm gonna say
that it's really
it's really the fruity for us that's
causing a major problem
both of us both danny and i are laying
claim to fruity
and there's not enough food to go around
and i'm the one who has a podcast
so i'm just saying i think that it
should go to me it tastes
amazing honestly too good to be true
it's not one of those things where
you're like oh
this health food like you can tell that
it has no sugar in it because it tastes
bad
no this food is keto friendly
gluten-free grain free soy free low carb
and gmo free and it actually tastes good
legitimately it tastes good i eat both
of it as random snacks throughout the
day and i don't have to feel bad that
i'm having a bowl of cereal
as a random snack actually i mean you
should never feel bad about having a
bowl of cereal as a random snack have
whatever
amount you want but
it's healthier than like your normal
bowl of cereal that's what i'm gonna
tell you so go to magicspoon.com
roast and grab a variety pack and try it
today
and be sure to use our promo code roast
at checkout to get free shipping and
magic spoon is so
confident in their product that is
backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason
if it doesn't cause strife in your home
the way that it did in mind
i'll refund you the money no questions
asked and you i mean you still get to
keep the cereal they don't want the old
they don't want the old cereal back so
you know you could give it to somebody
else that's magicspoon.com
roast and use the code roast for free
shipping we thank magic spoon for
sponsoring this podcast
today's episode of the roast of your
teenage self podcast
is brought to you by candid
candid get the experience of
having braces without actually having to
have
braces or feel like a teenager again
you're an adult
you want to straighten your teeth what
are your options your options
are candid candid clear aligners are
comfortable removable and practically
invisible unlike wire
braces we've all seen an adult with wire
braces
my mom one time made the choice to be an
adult with wire braces and i don't
i don't begrudge anybody their choices
but i'm saying that's a hard road to
walk
and i don't want that for my listeners
so you can transform your smile
without anyone noticing with candid plus
your treatment is prescribed and
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
movement
and it's all done from the comfort of
your own home candid only works with
orthodontists
never never general dentists like other
companies not to say anything weird
about dentists we all love a dentist
but when you're moving your teeth around
you want to be talking to an
orthodontist
and with candid your treatment includes
remote monitoring
by the same orthodontist who created
your plan
you'll never have to wonder how you're
doing you'll always know
i love that i love having a dedicated
orthodontist who's thinking about me
myself and my chompers
i don't know if i like calling teeth
chompers i think maybe we'll not do that
in future ads um the average candid
treatment is six months and you'll start
seeing results way before then
and hello it cost thousands less than
braces
thousands i don't know if you have
thousands lying around that you could
spend
to have metal braces i don't know why
you'd want to do that
when you could spend less and have
invisible braces this seems like kind of
a no-brainer to me
so start straightening your teeth today
right now all of my listeners can save
on candid starter kit go to candidco.com
teen self use code teen self that's
candid co.com
slash teen self code teen self and take
advantage of this
limited time offer to save 75 on your
starter kit
candidco.com teen cell code
teen self straighten those teeth but do
it private
it's nobody's business
yeah they have to write new vagina
monologues because there aren't enough
right for sure and they're just god
ah what a vagina is doing these days um
some of this is written by you bensler
some of this is written by jessica
that's so funny um
but it's so interesting that like a
comedy writer was tacked on to your job
as class president
it is weirdly like formative for my
whole
life i think cause getting to write that
sketch i was the vice president freshman
year
and we crushed we had the best sketch of
all the four classes i think in my
memory
which is probably deeply flawed also i
probably did a garbage job writing and i
was like 15 years old
but if you looked back at it you would
be like
this doesn't make sense yeah does this
video tape come with poison
because i need both at once um for
myself
but so that went well
and and i was like basically class
president on the strength
of sketch comedy writing for the next
three years like for real
it was like the reason i was class
president was like people didn't hate me
like i got along with people
so it wasn't like i was like like who's
this guy but i like
got along with a lot of people because i
did all these different activities and
was pretty social
and then also the position
like class president is also like head
writer for the
writer's carnival ball yeah which is a
very sexy
well it's it's also weirdly sexy
it's there's like this weird so it's a
variety show
but also at the beginning there there's
and it's hosted by usually seniors um
but i kind of i think i did i was like a
deputy host
my junior year and then hosted with two
friends um emily
and carolyn my senior year and the three
of us it was super fun
um but so it's this
um a variety show with hosts doing
comedy bits as much as like 17 year olds
do comedy bits
and then uh singers and dancers
but at the beginning there's a court
that's voted on by the um
senior class and it's 10 i don't know if
it's different now but when i did it
it was 10 boys and 10 girls
young men and young women and they would
do like a ballroom
dance like paired up like a debutante
ball
i assume that harry potter yes it's like
yes whatever you're picturing it's
exactly that open the dance by all
dancing together
the champions dude it's so
weird uh that that's like part of it and
then they
sit in the back like way upstage unless
they're like
in a sketch or doing a you know talent
performance they sit
watching from behind like down yeah so
like they're
the royalty because they're taught so
being entertained
being entertained yes they have to be
behind the performance
correct because everyone else has to see
it too so they yeah
actually the performance is for all of
the other people but you guys
correct yeah yeah yeah so it's like
everybody watches them
watching everything it's like very it's
fascinating um i love this and i
honestly think that
when things get back to normal we should
bring carna carnival ball to new york
hell yeah
anyone in the city is eligible oh yes
anyone can do a town
yeah for sure it's gonna be on the court
or it can be on the court that's true
great that's beautiful thank you yeah so
that would be so fun or it'd be like
okay it's the
um it's like the wall street bull is on
the court for some reason
and then aaron judge yes um
ariana grande
[Laughter]
just like one kind of like cool lady
from the train whoever yeah
the lady who sells churros on the subway
is there exactly
it's like a perfect it's honestly a
great court
and they will be amazing quick
performance for them
and she's she's doing like a dance with
um mitchell robinson from the knicks at
the beginning
yeah new york you new yorkers of all
strife
um okay we're off the top we've got
these kind of way off the top like when
i start talking about carnival
ball it just spins any conversation out
in weird directions
because everyone has questions like what
and really and
no for real so it always like derails
any conversation because it's like
i i grew up it's a pretty i grew up in a
pretty small town there's about 23 000
people and so but it has these
it was just one of those things where i
didn't realize like
my prom and stuff like there wasn't a
prom king and queen
we only did homecoming once every four
years
see we did it while you're in school our
fall team wasn't like a huge
rallying point for the school like for
school spirit and stuff
like we had other teams that really our
soccer teams were much better and but
like
it just so it wasn't like um
high school like you would see in movies
and stuff like it wasn't like that she's
all that high school or whatever
or bayside high from um from
uh saver the bell other than just my
hair but
the um but it also there's stuff about
it that i didn't realize was like
specifically weird until like carnival
ball until i like told people
like went to college moved to new york
and like was telling people from other
places and they were like
no that's not that's that's not anything
that's like you're
i don't have a frame of reference for
what you're describing
yeah we definitely did not have a
carnival ball at my
high school okay i feel like we didn't
get to
oh please yeah whatever you exact ways
in which it was sexy
i think it was the the dance the kind of
like so it wasn't like
sexy but it was like intensely
heterosexual
that's how it just felt like
like what a um i mean again this was
like
the early arts and my school was like
for that time i think pretty progressive
there weren't a lot of students like
queer students who were like out there
were a few
and it wasn't i don't think like i don't
remember it as being a place that was
like
openly hostile or that kind of hostility
would be like fostered and allowed
big picture but it also is so weird
to be like boys and girls dance with
each other right like if you're like the
10 best boys
you dance with the 10 best girls and
it's like what are we
what is this yeah right that's just like
as it's always been and then
uh maybe some of you will have uh
daughters at some point or tons together
like and again not none of i don't blame
the people like the kids like this was
just all we knew and
it's such a strange little tradition
so let's talk about so you're doing all
these different clubs you're
you're class president your head writer
of the school
head writer of the stone of high school
class of 2003.
um so what what was your like outside of
school
social life like were you drinking at
all partying at all
anything i did not i didn't drink
but i was i wasn't like averse to being
around it like i would i have a friend
who i
will not name uh because i don't know
how much of this is in the open
but like i had a friend who would have
parties for like the older kids
like when we were men and sophomores the
older kids would like show up with beer
and stuff
and and it was it was never like that
wild but like i would be at those
parties and i was like oh i'm not really
a drinker but like i don't
feel weird being here i wasn't like
oh no ah i gotta homework
um but so
and i had a child my childhood friends
like that i went to
summer camp with and stuff that lived a
couple towns over i would hang out with
and they were like a little more
adventurous than i was too so like
i was around friends who would like
drink a little bit or like you know i
had high school friends who were like
smoking cigarettes or probably like a
little weed or whatever
that like it just never was i was just
like too
uh fixated on being like a good
high achieving kid and so i wasn't
judgey but i also wasn't like
fun well so
would your friends like try to pressure
you much like the recent
campaign on twitter to try to pressure
you to do cocaine
cocaine it was
no i think people were and you've been
harassed as an adult man i get harassed
appear pressured
um by comedians matt cough and paul f
tompkins and others but
um as a kid i think people usually i
mean like
i i was a pretty good get along kid so
like
occasionally people would be like oh do
you want it like
oh you want to be here i'd be like oh no
thanks all right like it wasn't it
was not a high pressure situation for me
really or
i didn't notice because i'm like a like
smiley dummy
but even even in college i didn't really
drink like i didn't really start
drinking until like
my mid-20s maybe
um yeah so basically
we're finding that the comedy community
at large is our worst peer pressures
than like high schools yeah for sure no
doubt about that yeah i will say that
for sure
uh my my current peers much worse peer
pressure than when i was a kid well it's
also like
well what i care what these uh 17 year
olds think of me
like they're 17. they don't know
anything i don't know anything
um but i know i like but i have such
that sounds so
so cold but like i have like really
mostly very fond memories of the people
that i like went to school with
and i'm in touch with a bunch of people
still so that's what i was gonna ask is
um two questions so you mentioned camp
did you have like a camp that you went
to
every year i did it wasn't an overnight
camp though
so it was like a day camp that i went to
for years
up until i was like a cit at age 14 as a
counselor in training and then
i was like oh that's enough of that um
and
and so i have a group of childhood
friends that i
one of whom i mean the reason i went to
that camp was because my best friend
from preschool
went there and so i went and like met
this other
group of friends that like he already
knew when we were like
seven eight years old and so like these
are guys that i i mean like i'm in a um
group chat with a lot of them still and
like talk to them you know
talk pretty frequently one-on-one as
well and like try to see people when i'm
home
so did you like would it be like i've
got my school friends during the school
year but then in the summer
i'm camp josh um it was it was like a
juggling thing because i i don't think i
was like that different a dude
i wasn't like when i go to camp i put my
sunglasses on
and i never had a guitar um it was like
they were these were guys that like i
was friends with year round too so
it and the their town that they they
were all living in or the
couple towns were like 15 20 25 minutes
away depending on
exactly where everyone was and so it
would
like it was much easier when i started
driving but like until then
my parents are very gracious about like
i you know i would like sometimes
stay overnight for like a night or two
uh
with friends like on the weekends and
stuff and just hang out
yeah okay so what was your
dating situation let's pull up the
screech photo again
please let's talk about
how teen josh did with the ladies
how how did that play out
i think so i'm sorry so here's that's me
this is what i was working with
um this and this is like
the apex of my hair having like because
i've i've my hair thinned out really
young
uh and so this is like uh this is like
the last hurrah like when i was 17 and
18.
and then it was all downhill from there
um
i did i i dated i had a girlfriend for
most of high school
um the same girlfriend for most of high
school where did you meet her
how did you met we met doing plays
together
uh okay the perfect romance so to walk
me through
um you got to tell me the play
i wish i remembered like maybe we met
doing my first
show which was um wizard of oz
was the first one that i was what i did
gosh you just said the magic words of
this podcast
did i yes because i
i find every opportunity at least once
an episode today that i played glinda in
my school's production
wow very nice that's exciting
and i was wondering when am i going to
say it here it is
and you just linda huge i played
um i i had like a bunch of like chorus
parts so i was like one of the flying
monkeys
and like a citizen of the of the land of
oz but i
my named part was i was uncle henry
well that's a good part it was pretty
good and but you
because he's only really there at the
beginning in the end
they i was like all these other little
parts too which was fun yeah
you can be like a monkey in between all
that i was so
snooty that my freshman year when i
when they offered me the chorus i was
like no
i won't be in the chorus and it's like
just be in the chorus of little shop
it'll be fun after school
what are you mad about yeah like what
right
what what do you lose out on by doing
that you're not good at singing that's
why you're not in the play
so just go be in the chorus they're
being nice to you
um i don't know how to sing the songs
yeah oh i was not i'm i'm like an
i i'm like a c singer
like not uh bad
can carry a tune but like once you get
into like okay then you
harmonize on the fifth and i'm like nope
absolutely
i shan't i would give myself a b
in that i think if you give me a song in
a certain range that's pretty
straightforward i could like
sing a pretty good version of that song
okay
so like that's kind of to get in a high
school musical that's about
enough skills you really need but again
as soon as it's like
okay now you're gonna harmonize with
this person i'm like
i couldn't yeah tell you
so we did and i did so that was my first
play um
and then we did uh
what was the musical my sophomore year
grease
was fun you did grease and then i did
then we did fiddler on the roof we had a
non-jewish tevye which i find
anti-semitic
i don't really but and then we did
a basically all-white version of once on
this
island which is slightly problematic
there wasn't like problematic makeup
involved
but it was like like again we it's like
a mostly white
high school we were like 17.
or 18 in 2003 there i just did not have
the aware like i think i would have
known like
oh blackface is wrong of course but like
just reading the text of this play
i was like all right sure
there's two people on an island and
they're in love yep
exactly uh right tamiya it was like
sure i mean they're still doing west
side story that's no weirder to do with
all white people
yeah i think there was at one point talk
of my high school doing hairspray but it
got quashed pretty fast
if that one you can't really i mean
there are high schools who have done it
but you really
can't it doesn't make sense right
yeah it's just visually confusing have
actual black people
in the show so it would would be
confusing
no real reason to push that issue with
all white
or mostly so are these people mad at
each other
yeah right right right this seems like
how do how do they what does he know
about her
let him dance i don't know let him dance
is this they're what are they mad he's
italian
i guess that guy's
i guess that guy's italian that's what
the play would have been called instead
of hairspray
i guess that guy's italian and the whole
town's mad
oh they're so mad um but yeah i met we i
met my high school girlfriend doing
doing theater and were you guys like
i mean what were you like a theater
couple was that yeah yeah
yeah for sure your reputation as a
couple
yep and she was a grade ahead of me um
so what did you do when she went to
college or did you guys get that far
we did we stayed together the year she
went to college she went to
to college in boston and so i would
visit her there and she
ended up i think after her first
semester maybe moving
living at home and commuting to school
so we and and she
so we would hang out in in town still um
and you know we had like lots of friends
that were like
still in lots of friends over my year in
high school lots of friends that were
her year that like went to school nearby
so we would like see them like we would
congregate places and then
we broke up my freshman year of college
so when you were when it was time for
you to spread your wings
yeah um i mean i think i
was just very i like just wasn't um
i'm just like not a good especially then
was not like a good
adult communicator of like things that
i wanted from a relationship or like so
i i feel
i mean i feel very bad for everyone
who's ever
dated me with the possible exclusion of
my wife to whom i am married
i mean now and into the future forever
feel exactly the same i was like so i
like dated around when i was
in high school and i was oh i was
horrible
at dating someone even while
even while not being like a monster just
like the things that i had internalized
that you do
in a relationship from tv was like the
most dramatic [ __ ] that you could
possibly do so i was always embroiled in
like
some sort of high drama of romance i was
always i aming one boy
and like dating another boy and i was
like this is how it's supposed to be
and it's like no you could also just
i think that there are a lot of adults
that too
that are still like wrapped up like
how matic they think relationships are
supposed to be or like
what how how bad
still qualifies as normal right like how
bad they can be or how
that's still like but we make it work
and it's like
we just we'll stop that don't just like
date someone that you like and that
likes you
yeah it's actually you're like you're
making something work that doesn't need
to be like let it be broken and just
move forward i mean
i i feel that uh a lot like i was
i was in a i was in a drama love
triangle wow
um my senior year and my like
oc obsessed brain was like
oh my god this is what love is
it's right it's exciting you're desired
you're like just everything feels so
intense
everybody's talking about me and i feel
terrible all the time and i'm actually
being really really mean to this one boy
and this other boy is a monster
but i get to feel like i'm the lady tied
to the train tracks and everyone's
trying to save me
and it took a long time to like shed
that and just be like it's actually a
lot cooler to just be
two normal people talking
it's so much so much better but it's
just like
it's so hard i think at that age when
you like
are still figuring out like how to be a
person
and like yeah it's i so it's it's tough
and i feel yeah but i think just being
with someone you like and who likes you
is such a uh an underrated part of being
in relationships
and like that you don't have to wait for
there to be some explosive
moment to break up with someone like
you could just break up because you
don't want to be dating anyone anymore
you like somebody else and that's
actually allowed
and all of that stuff so i feel like
when i was in high school i would
concoct like explosive breakup moments
just because like but that's because
that's how you have to break up with
someone like you have to
have some giant what uh whatever someone
has to cheat on someone
or like someone has to like forget your
birthday and it's just like exactly i i
think like it took me
into my mid-twenties to win with
somebody that i dated for
quite some time to to go oh
this just like we're trying really hard
because we're two
people that like each other and are not
neither of us is a bad person
but like i think i think
we've we've flourished this relationship
has like
flourished to the degree it's going to
and
it's like the churn of trying to like
get it to a place where we're both happy
and the kind of like
constant like compromise that we're both
kind of attempting for the other one
is like oh this just isn't the right
relationship for us to be in
yeah it takes such a long time to
learn what a normal healthy relationship
is actually supposed to look
and feel like because you learn so much
about relationships i mean
you maybe you have a good one modeled
for you
at home maybe you don't but all the rest
is like tv where people
you know i i was never a twilight person
but like the twilight books came out
kind of the end of my high school and
this guy's like stalking her every move
like watching sleep
really romantic he doesn't sleep and he
just walks
asleep and he falls around in a ghost
form
it's like my wife and i have been
watching
cheers which i've never seen just like
beginning to end
like the last few months we've been
watching and
this like i kind of had this awareness
of like
the sam and diane push and pull of like
will they won't they on again off again
and then when you watch those seasons
the like first four or five seasons
their relationship is horrible
it's like unbelievable like if you if
two people in your life were acting like
that
you would like sit there when you're
closer to johnny's like you have to stop
it like hurts me to see you this way
it is painful it's painful happy
they unhappy i'm everyone around you is
uncomfortable watching
this happen over and over and it it's
like air out of every room you do
yes everyone's like eavesdropping on you
because you're constantly
fighting at the top of your voice in at
your workplace
where all your friends also work
it's so it's so toxic
in a way that like i don't think it's
just like
oh this didn't age well i was like i
can't imagine
seeing as there are like seasons where
it was like it made a little more sense
of like oh they kind of like get under
each other's skin
in a way where like they can't stop
thinking about each other and they're
uncomfortable with how strongly they
feel for the others
but then like by the end they're just
like playing
pranks on each other like like canceling
engagements to be mean to each other
and it's like this is horrible to watch
so when you were in high school you're
saying you're watching cheers now but
when you were in high school what were
your like go
to like what was your music pop culture
oh boy
of choice i'm trying to think of like
okay the music stuff is the it comes the
most naturally
to like to remember and think back to it
was
a lot of like early to mid what
what's now become i guess it's all early
at this point weezer like the first
several years of weezer
was big for me uh the drama club
was very ben folds
so a lot of that um was getting real
into like kind of way
alternative like experimental hip-hop
at that age yeah well i'm like a big
hip-hop person so like starting a
hip-hop person
like the dorkiest jewish thing um
i'm kind of the hip hopsman um but i
like listen i got like
really into rap music at like
seventh eighth grade and so it was a lot
of like
what was contemporary then and then
backfilling the stuff that i was like
reading about online because i had
the internet and i would like read on
forums and stuff like oh okay i should
listen to this big
album this is like thing so this is
probably we're talking
eight eight years after it came out five
years after he
died was like okay i'm back filling this
like
edu musical education and rap music but
then oh sorry go ahead
no oh i was just gonna ask are you so
are you
like buying cds at this time
so my girlfriend in high school had a
much better
internet connection and she would i
would like request cds and she would
burn for me it's very sweet of her to
indulge that
and that was like a very nice thing she
did for me um but i would also
i lived walking distance to like uh
i mean record stores where but it was
like cds dvds vhs at that point
like one of those it was like a
strawberries coconuts
um and so we would that was like a big
thing we would do after school is like
browse there and like
buy a cd every week um and so yeah
and so i got into this like very
way out i think i was probably like by
the end of high school
reading pitchfork at that point
i think that's right and so there was
like
all this like the the def jux stuff
i was really into which is like lp from
um
run the jewels his like record label
that he had
in like the early aughts so all this
stuff was coming out that was like
cannibal ox and his own music and so i
was
really i was like dove really hard into
that
were your friends into this too or was
this just like a private
endeavor you were going on and you're
like
mo like in your little massachusetts
school my
so i i hung out like i had acquaintances
that were like
deeper into like listening to rap stuff
but they like by the time
i was in high school we like didn't have
that many classes together
we weren't we didn't have that many
activities that we did together
and it was like my my childhood friends
that were really into that stuff too
so like my friends that i would see at
camp and on the weekend on the weekends
in high school basically
uh were into that but there was also
like more mainstream
rock stuff that i'm sure i was listening
like i'm trying to think of just like
what was popular then
like it was very fashionable to be like
very
band in a way that was like very
unnecessary for like
dudes in the you know in like 2001 2002
to be like being a boy band yeah just
like
you know yeah um but like the
ben folds kind of like
singer-songwritery stuff uh
i'm trying to think of what else i
listen to but like that i remember like
i would drive my sister i have a younger
sister
and i would drive her to like uh dance
class after school
senior year and we would listen to like
weezer and uh and ben folds were like
the the two that i'm like
coming to mind or like you know mixed
cds of like
a bunch of different stuff i had so many
cds and like i can't remember
what else i was listening to then i had
so many and i mean also like my friends
and i were always
burning mixed cd for each other because
we had that good internet
yeah it was like right before everyone
had good internet that i knew
i remember i downloaded so
many viruses on the home computer
and my parents would be like what is
happening to the home computer and i
would just like
i don't know it's crazy how would you
who can say
you'll never know who could possibly
know
well how the home computer keeps getting
so many viruses i don't know who's
downloading
so much porn accidentally that has the
same name as like various pop punk
albums sure
[Laughter]
yeah that's i mean like there was some
like embarrassing stuff too like i feel
like limp bizkit was in the air in kind
of an embarrassing way
um stuff like that i was not a tool
person that was like
that that kind of um like industrial
stuff like loses me a little bit
but we so we would go to this place and
there was a guy that
that worked at the strawberries or
coconuts or whatever it was at the time
and whatever you bought
he would be like dude he's psyched for
this so like my friend
chris bought the ramstein album like the
one
that they had that one big single
duhaust and uh he
there i remember this guy the guy behind
the camera being like dude he's psyched
for ramstein yeah man
and my friend being like yeah and he'd
be like yeah this rules you psyched man
it's just like you would say that for
like whatever you bought was very
excited
oh that's that's such a fun like local
like cd store guy yeah very fun
um yeah it was like a lot of like
kind of alternative hip-hop like my
my maybe it was right after my
senior year my girlfriend and i went to
it was called the smoke and grooves tour
and the lineup was
bonkers it was um
it was ceelo performing solo
before he was like a big solo deal like
when he had just left goody
mom um
jurassic five i was very 18 at the time
um
i think tweet was her name she had a
song that was like oops there goes my
it's like a big enough one hit wonder at
the time and she like
canceled she was sick and then tweet
the roots the roots played who are like
one of my all-time favorite bands and
then
outcast closed oh my god with
i think killer mike came just to do his
verse
on the whole world that's like what he
it was like outcast's greatest hits that
era
that's like to have heard what year was
that about i think it was summer of a
three to see
outcast in the summer of 03.
very cool very exciting it was like i i
was like oh
i did at some point have like kind of
good taste and stuff
okay i have two more questions please
number one
do you remember any like big
rumors or scandals from
your high school
oh that's a good question um
the one that i always give as an example
is i remember that there was a girl
who rumored put a remote control in her
butt at a party
and i remember hearing about it on the
bus and everyone was like
party got pretty crazy gosh i don't
remember like i don't remember any of
the fun ones the one
that was when we were high school aged
the one that i fell for because i was
like credulous dweeb
was that my my camp friends and i
heard that like we were like 16 that
another kid we went to camp with who
we like weren't as friendly with we just
like knew him we would see him didn't
hang out outside of camp
we heard that he overdosed on marijuana
and almost died
oh no he was pulled from the grips of
marijuana death
yep saw a green light went towards it
thank god but that was like narcon
in time
he was like uh this is doing nothing for
me i just i just need like
uh mountain dew yeah i actually think if
i just sit down
could you put on some music that's like
what would
would fix remember like what like so he
just didn't show up to
camp no this was like during the school
year so like
yeah so it was like we heard through
someone who
knows and like went to you know like
someone from his town told someone that
because it was people from you know from
a bunch of different towns um so that
was like the rumor
honestly over that some of them some kid
od'd on marijuana and almost died is a
great
very funny like incredibly i like i
think i like told my parents and my
i think my dad didn't want to be like
that's dumb because he didn't want to be
like
no that does nothing but i think he was
like i'm pretty sure he'll be okay
i don't think i don't think you should
stay up too late yeah
right right right right cancel the vigil
you've planned
all right we've come to our final
question i asked this of all of my
guests
if you could talk to teen
josh today yeah what would you tell
him oh great question
i think that this is something that that
i learned
a lot over the years um but it
it definitely would be relevant to teeny
which is like
it's you don't have to
lead with self-deprecation to sh
like you can be kind and you can be
respectful to people
without leading with like life i suck
right
yeah like i think i do that
diminishingly
as an adult and and when i do like when
i make self-deprecating jokes
it is because i think they're funny and
not because i'm like
trying to put myself down to you know to
make other people
comfortable with my what i perceive to
be my place in like a social hierarchy
um
and so i think like teen me it would
just be like hey man
it's okay to like be the way you are
and and like the stuff you do and like
to
to not you know to like playing sports
but not be good at them like you don't
have to like
feel bad or weird like you don't have to
feel like
oh i'm i'm like out of place in this
group because i
i don't have like the same kind of skill
and and drive and athleticism or
whatever
and so that that's definitely something
i think i could have learned
earlier oh well i feel like that's such
a good i i'm
i mean that's a thing that i struggle
with
myself but i feel like that's so good
for teens because again
i think it goes back to what we were
talking about it's like you kind of see
the character of
screech cohen's the like funny guy
who's always kind of making a comment
about himself
and that's kind of the nature of his
charm and it
makes you see that as like a
verifiable strategy to get liked when
you don't actually have to do it
right and especially like probably
people will just be fine with you just
like
being okay like just like nobody is like
i can't wait for this guy to like i hope
this guy knows he sucks
or whatever like and then i'll think
he's cool right like it just doesn't
like you don't it's not even not even
like a
uh dating confidence it's just like a
friendship confidence of like
um entering a situation and like not
feeling like you have to
like triangulate so like just being okay
and like being
being eddies like putting i think like
putting across that you're at ease and
finding ways to feel
comfortable in yourself is probably
harder than than it is like as an adult
who's like
accomplished things and has a job but it
is
it is so that like is yours and no one
can
knock on your door right what are you
doing right they could be like hey come
down
we gotta be at nana's in an hour it's
like if if i'm late to
a relative's house it's like my own
fault and then i have to deal with the
consequences yeah
then i have to like my mom's like kind
of annoyed with me when i get there and
i deal with that but
yeah yeah well i think that's a perfect
place for us to end it josh thank you so
much for coming on the pod it was so
great for having me what a pleasure and
for everyone listening at home
this has been the roast of your teenage
self podcast
you